vamos a las noticias de salud con Mara
Romero sala maro Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela vamos a comenzar en
Reino Unido con una prueba de sangre que
podría detectar varios tipos de Cáncer y
que tiene unos resultados que son
prometedores sí podemos decirlo con
seguridad son prometedores Aunque por
supuesto falta camino por recorrer
Ángeles se llama el test gallery lleva
ya dando vueltas un rato no es el primer
estudio que se hace ya se está aplicando
en algunos lugares de Estados Unidos
pero ahora tenemos el resultado
preliminar de un estudio que está
haciendo a gran escala los servicios de
salud de Reino Unido las nhs de 5.000
personas con algunos síntomas de cáncer
es decir que ya sospechaban que podían
tener la enfermedad se sometieron a esta
prueba de sangre y el test tuvo un
resultado correcto digamos Dos de cada
tres veces en dos tercios de las pruebas
dicho de otra forma de todos los test
positivos es decir que notificaban que
la persona tenía cáncer el 75% luego se
mostró que efectivamente padecía la
enfermedad y de estos el 85% además en
el 85% de los casos se pudo saber de
dónde dónde se estaba originando este
cáncer una información muy útil de los
que dieron test negativo Igualmente
había igual un 2,5% de personas que sí
tenían cáncer finalmente es decir
resultados prometedores pero vemos que
igualmente hay falsos positivos no un
25% de los test positivos luego
revelaron que no había la enfermedad y
también por supuesto en este 2,5% vemos
que también hay casos de cáncer que se
escapan a este test está llamado a
revolucionar la detección del cáncer
pero pues claramente todavía hay algunas
cosas por afinar no absolutamente
angustiante ser por ejemplo un falso
positivo de cáncer mar Pero bueno vamos
a andar un poco sobre cómo funciona esta
prueba de cáncer Sí este este test
galeritis ayuda de las novedades que
existen en la tecnología de
secuenciación de ADN y también en el
aprendizaje automático del que tanto
hablamos además últimamente a raíz de la
inteligencia Inteligencia artificial
básicamente Lo que sucede es que las
células cancerosas emiten lo que se
llama
cfd es decir material genético ADN que
está fuera de las células en este caso
se encuentra en el torrente sanguíneo al
sacar una muestra de sangre y pues
secuenciar investigar que se encuentra
en esta muestra de sangre se pueden
encontrar estos restos de ADN de las
células tumorales de las células
cancerosas y también en algunos de los
casos como veíamos incluso identificar
desde dónde se están emitiendo Y dónde
se halla este cáncer por supuesto
gracias a estas nuevas tecnologías
afinamos cada vez más la detección de
las enfermedades de cáncer pero no
podemos dejar de decir que hay algunos
escépticos de este test para empezar no
está todavía aprobado por la fda la
agencia de medicamentos de Estados
Unidos ahí se distribuye solamente
gracias a un programa para invenciones
digamos con potencial Revolucionario que
le llaman ahí Es muy caro cuesta 494
949 Perdón dólares un solo test Y por
supuesto esto que nos imaginamos cuando
nos dicen que un test de sangre puede
detectar cáncer que nos imaginamos
someternos entonces toda la población a
irlo probando no para mejorar la
detección temprana mientras siga este
precio mientras sigan Pues en este costo
es imposible el costo de someter por
ejemplo a toda la población
estadounidense a estos test de sangre es
absolutamente inviable y luego hay
varios miedos uno el que tú mencionabas
la angustia de estos falsos positivos de
detectarte Que tengan un cáncer y luego
que los siguientes exámenes no lo
encuentren Será que es realmente un
falso positivo o será que todavía es tan
pequeño que no lo hayan vivir es vivir
con un miedo durante mucho tiempo luego
también sabemos que hay tumores pequeños
que el cuerpo mismo se encarga de
eliminar entonces podría haber un sobre
diagnóstico no personas que de otra
forma se consideraría que están sanas
tuvieron un pequeño tumor no se detectó
pasó sin darse cuenta
Terminan sometiéndose entonces a
tratamientos duros no para combatir el
cáncer Y por último y quizás lo que me
parece más importante es recordar que la
detección temprana en sí del cáncer no
es el objetivo el objetivo es reducir la
mortalidad por cáncer entonces Todavía
falta ver si realmente este test puede
reducir la mortalidad por cáncer y no
solo ayudar a detectarlo antes Entonces
eso es especialmente importante en este
sentido todavía por supuesto se están
manejando estudios con cientos de miles
de personas a mayor escala que por
supuesto nos darán respuestas a estas
dudas bueno y nuevas evidencias en otros
temas de la salud de que el contacto
piel a pieles tiene más y más beneficios
para los bebés recién nacidos Sí
particularmente el método madre canguro
cuidados canguros para bebés prematuros
que consisten cargar al recién nacido No
desde el momento de su nacimiento la OMS
organizó un estudio que comparaba los
bebés que habían nacido prematuramente y
que directamente habían llegado a la
incubadora y no se ponía en el cuidado
canguro hasta después de estar
estabilizados y los bebés que en cambio
directamente recibieron este tipo de
cuidados vemos que hay diferencias
abismales bajan los casos de presuntas
sepsis que es una reacción del cuerpo a
la infección se reducen las muertes
relacionadas con la sepsis y también las
muertes totales la OMS recomienda
empezar el cuidado tipo canguro lo antes
posible después del nacimiento Exacto a
raíz de estas conclusiones la OMS ha
cambiado su recomendaciones y ahora
muestra que los hospitales deberían
adoptar estas medidas y también
reformular sus unidades de cuidados
intensivos para que puedan cuidar tanto
a los bebés recién nacidos prematuros
como a las madres o las gestantes a la
vez no la recomendación por lo tanto es
que en un bebé prematuro pueda recibir
este cuidado canguro este pie la piel
inmediatamente sabemos que reduce la
hipotermia que mejora la alimentación y
que además es un método fácilmente
aplicable en todo el mundo no requiere
muchas inversiones por lo tanto
esperemos que estas nuevas
recomendaciones puedan salvar muchas más
vidas sobre eso le quería hablar tan
fácil que es llevar a cabo algunos
procedimientos y tanto bien que nos
pueden hacer muchas gracias a usted
Gracias Ángela